este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a sur
shark vpn luego los demás detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ha pasado más de un mes desde el inicio
de la invasión de ucrania y las tropas
rusas ya han sufrido su primera gran
derrota han tenido que abandonar el
sitio de kif después de varias semanas
intentando tomar la capital ucraniana a
estas alturas ya se puede decir alto y
claro porque el ejército ruso funciona
tan mal como es posible que no hayan
sido capaces en un mes de tomar ninguna
ciudad importante en el vídeo de hoy no
vamos a hablar de las atrocidades
cometidas por el ejército ruso vamos a
centrarnos únicamente en estrategia
militar y en cuestiones puramente
técnicas pensando así esto es el
ejército ruso y esto es el ejército
ucraniano en otras palabras que no hay
punto de comparación rusia tiene un
ejército muy superior al de ucrania
además si algo caracteriza a la rusia de
putin es precisamente la cultura
militarista
nos lo hemos contado aquí en visual
político el kremlin ha llegado a
construir una catedral dedicada a sus
fuerzas armadas todos esperábamos que en
cuestión de días los soldados rusos
capturarían kyi las principales
capitales del país sin embargo ha pasado
más de un mes y rusia todavía no ha sido
capaz de tomar ninguna ciudad importante
es más según algunas fuentes rusia lleva
más de 20 mil bajas contando muertos y
heridos para que os hagáis una idea
estas cifras superan las bajas que
sufrió el ejército americano durante los
20 años que duró la guerra de afganistán
por supuesto que los ucranianos también
están sufriendo muchísimas bajas pero
seamos honestos era de esperar
supuestamente quienes tenían todos los
ases en la manga eran los rusos de hecho
de otra forma que el ejército ruso ya
contaba con varios fracasos en su
historia pero todos esperábamos que esas
reformas de putin estarían funcionando y
diréis pero de qué fracasos hablamos
pues veréis desde chechenia hasta
georgia todas las guerras que ha librado
rusia han sido victorias amargas rusia
ganó las guerras de chechenia pero lo
hizo a cambio de perder a miles de
soldados y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos no estaréis haciendo
propaganda anti rusa y la respuesta es
que no es más el propio vladimir putin
era consciente de que su ejército no
estaba preparado para la guerra moderna
y precisamente por eso en el año 2008 el
kremlin puso todos sus recursos para
poner a su ejército en el siglo 21 para
eso putin contaba con dos figuras
fundamentales hablamos de sergei shoigú
el ministro de defensa y valeri
guerásimov el que ahora es el general
jefe del estado mayor ruso quiero que os
quedéis especialmente con este nombre
valeri guerásimov si sois veteranos
seguidores de visual política este
nombre os resultará muy familiar porque
es toda una rockstar del ejército
respetado por toda la comunidad militar
incluidos sus adversarios de la otan
a la lista
muchos dirían que es el padre
intelectual del concepto de la nueva
generación de guerra de hecho todos
absolutamente todos pensábamos que con
grassi mueva la cabeza las fuerzas
armadas rusas abandonarían la herencia
soviética y entrarían de lleno en el
siglo 21 sin embargo estamos viendo que
en rusia todavía persiste ese viejo
adagio que tantas veces se repetía en
época de la unión soviética
la gente finge que trabaja y el gobierno
finge como que paga viejo proverbio
soviético en el vídeo de hoy vamos a
evitar centrarnos en la guerra de
ucrania tampoco vamos a hablar de las
armas rusas porque todo eso lo dejaremos
para otros dos vídeos que sacaremos en
las próximas semanas porque la pregunta
que hoy nos hacemos es por qué el
ejército ruso es semejante desastre que
falla exactamente en las fuerzas armadas
rusas cómo es posible que un país tan
autoritario y con una cultura tan
militarista tenga un ejército tan
caótico y desorganizado hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a hablar de defensa de
vuestro ordenador o de vuestro teléfono
móvil porque si el internet está lleno
de hackers rusos y de todas partes del
mundo y una forma de evitar buena parte
de estos saqueos es utilizando una vpn y
diréis cual es la vpn favorita de visual
político y ya lo sabéis todos surf shark
vpn y creedme el tema de la
ciberseguridad se lo toman muy pero que
muy en serio por ejemplo surf shark
tiene una herramienta que se llama clean
web que bloquea todos esos popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bots y de cookies no queremos tener
por si todo esto fuera poco con una
única cuenta de surf shark vpn podréis
registrar todos los dispositivos que
queráis queréis navegar con seguridad
desde vuestra smrtv o desde vuestro
teléfono móvil o desde vuestro ordenador
pues podéis hacer todo eso con una única
cuenta de surf shark vpn y por supuesto
tenemos una oferta muy especial para
todos vosotros que seguís visual
política básicamente si utilizáis el
código político terminado en que podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento más
tres meses extra totalmente gratuitos
tenéis el link en la descripción no
esperéis más y descargaros ya la
aplicación y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
y falta de formación
[Música]
todos hemos visto imágenes de soldados
rusos capturados por el ejército
ucraniano la propaganda ucraniana se ha
encargado de difundir las a bombo y
platillo para que todos veamos cómo
llaman por teléfono a sus madres sin
embargo hay algo muy interesante más
allá de la propaganda en estas imágenes
casi todos los soldados son muy jóvenes
en la mayoría ni siquiera tienen 20 años
y esto una cosa son soldados con muy
poca formación así es como se explica
que las tropas rusas están cayendo como
moscas ante el juego ucraniano así es
como se explican noticias como éstas
hablan de jarc y dos soldados rusos
fueron a la policía ucraniana a pedir
combustible diesel y a los esta noticia
es pura propaganda ucraniana pero es un
ejemplo más de los muchos que hemos
visto durante esta invasión vamos a
decirlo claro rusia tiene un problema
muy serio a la hora de entrenar a sus
soldados la mayoría de sus tropas son
reclutas que están haciendo el servicio
militar obligatorio para que os hagáis
una idea se estima que la cuarta parte
de las tropas de élite rusas los
llamados space nazi son reclutas y
diréis pero por qué pues para entender
esto nos tenemos que remontar a los
tiempos de la unión soviética
por aquellos años el servicio militar
obligatorio era de dos años
prácticamente todos los hombres
soviéticos tenían que servir en el
ejército va a llegar a la mayoría de
edad y esto tiene una ventaja la unión
soviética contaba con muchísimos
soldados pero también tiene un problema
dos años no son un tiempo suficiente
para formarse en la guerra moderna tras
la segunda guerra mundial las grandes
potencias principalmente eeuu y la unión
soviética entraron como ya sabéis todos
en una carrera militar pues bien cuanto
más complejas son las armas más tiempo
de formación necesitan esto explica
porque cada vez hay menos países que
tienen servicio militar obligatorio
desde hace varias décadas casi todos los
ejércitos han hecho un esfuerzo enorme
en profesionalizarse y rusia no es la
excepción precisamente por esto en el
año 2008 el kremlin redujo el servicio
militar obligatorio de dos años pasaron
a uno además el ejército lanzó una
enorme campaña de reclutamiento querían
contratar a soldados que estuvieran
dispuestos a hacer una carrera militar
soldados profesionales que pudieran
servir en el ejército durante varios
años para así poder adquirir la
experiencia necesaria en la guerra
moderna el problema el problema es que a
contratar soldados necesitas dos cosas
dinero y gente que quiero alistarse dos
cosas que escasean en rúsia
para que os hagáis una idea hoy en día
el ejército ruso tiene alrededor de 850
mil efectivos pues bien de éstos sólo
400 5.000 son soldados profesionales y
estos soldados profesionales no aguantan
muchos años en el ejército para que os
hagáis una idea un sargento de la otan
puede servir una media de entre 15 ó 20
años en rusia es raro encontrar soldados
que estén más de 4 por ejemplo un piloto
de caza de la otan tiene que hacer más
de doscientas horas de vuelo para poder
entrar en combate en rusia basta con 100
horas y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos pero entonces porque no tienen un
problema semejante en israel todos
sabemos que israel también tiene
servicio militar obligatorio tanto los
hombres como las mujeres israelíes
tienen que servir en el ejército durante
dos años sin embargo nadie diría que las
tropas israelíes estén mal entrenadas
que tiene israel que no tenga rusia pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ejército sin sargentos
en términos generales podríamos decir
que hay dos formas principales de entrar
en un ejército una es como soldado y
otra es como oficial los oficiales se
forman en academias en ese sentido rusia
no tiene nada que envidiar a ningún otro
ejército tanto los almirantes como los
coroneles y los generales rusos tienen
una formación equiparable a los de
cualquier otro país de nuevo nadie pone
en duda la profesionalidad de una figura
como el general valeri guerásimov el
problema es que un ejército necesita
algo más que reclutas y oficiales entre
medias hay una figura fundamental el
suboficial dicho de otra forma y
principalmente los sargentos los agentes
son soldados con años de experiencia que
pueden formar a los nuevos reclutas son
una figura clave en cualquier ejército y
aquí es donde rusia tiene un problema
muy grande pesado así se calcula que
sólo el 1 por ciento de los reclutas se
reenganchan en el ejército tras hacer al
servicio militar esto significa que hay
muy pocos sargentos que puedan formar a
los nuevos soldados y diréis pero por
quién nadie se quiere enganchar en el
ejército ruso no se supone que tienen
una cultura militarista que glorifica
las hazañas de sus fuerzas armadas
[Música]
recordad que putin ha llegado a crear
sus propias milicias juveniles es decir
que en principio los soldados rusos
tienen más fervor patriótico que los de
ningún otro país y si es cierto el sueño
de muchos jóvenes es alistarse y servir
a la madre patria pero una vez llegan al
ejército se encuentran con una auténtica
pesadilla quedaos con esta palabra de
dos china atentos un soldado ruso mata
disparos a ocho compañeros en una base
militar en siberia el soldado en
cuestión disparó a sus compañeros
después de sufrir meses de novatadas y
abusos la de dos china es la palabra
rusa para referirse a las novatadas para
que os hagáis una idea en el año 2006 el
suicidio era la causa de muerte del 40%
de los soldados en tiempos de paz sólo
en el año 2014 15 reclutas murieron por
las novatadas y como os podéis imaginar
con una cultura tan tóxica es lógico
pensar que la mayoría de los soldados
rusos no aguanten más de 4 años en el
ejército de hecho en el año 2009 rusia
abrió su primera academia de
suboficiales para intentar suplir esta
carencia de sargentos pero eso no es
suficiente cada año se gradúan 2000
suboficiales y russian a muchos más
conclusión ante la falta de sargentos
bien formados nos encontramos con
batallones dirigidos por reclutas con
sólo un año de experiencia así que como
tantas veces ocurría en la unión
soviética
los generales jóvenes fingen que dirigen
sus batallones y los reclutas fingen que
los obedecen y os preguntaréis pero de
verdad vladimir putin tiene la culpa de
que el ejército ruso funcione tan mal en
que ha consistido esta reforma del
ejército de la que tanto se ha hablado
en el kremlin donde está la influencia
del general valeri guerásimov pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
todos los hombres del presidente'
la pregunta que todos estaréis haciendo
ahora es pero cómo es posible que putin
haya cometido semejante error de cálculo
en la invasión de ucrania todo apuntaba
a que rusia esperaba una guerra
relámpago pensaban que el ejército
ucraniano no iba a resistir y que la
sociedad recibiría esos libertadores
rusos con los brazos abiertos
evidentemente no ha sido así
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la pregunta es y no había ningún
servicio de inteligencia asesorando a
vladimir putin pensamos que no hablamos
de un pequeño error de cálculo sino de
toda una invasión en toda regla donde
rusia lleva acumulando más de 20.000
bajas de verdad no hay nadie en el
ejército ruso que no se haya informado a
putin pues por extraño que parezca todo
apunta a que no de hecho no deja de ser
llamativa la ausencia de valeri
guerásimov en las últimas semanas pensad
que se trata de la rockstar del ejército
ruso o algo así como la versión rusia de
lo que fue en su día el general petraeus
en eeuu de verdad es realista pensar que
putin está micro gestionando la guerra
de ucrania pues en realidad no sería la
primera vez en la que un político se
dedica a microgestión a una guerra lo
vimos durante la guerra de vietnam en
este caso el por entonces presidente de
los eeuu lyndon johnson llegó a
gestionar los detalles más minuciosos
desde su despacho oval el resultado fue
la vergüenza más absoluta para el
ejército estadounidense además pensando
así durante años rusia ha evolucionado
en una dictadura personalista y esto
también afecta al ejército pensando así
durante la época soviética rusia era una
sin paliativos
ahora bien el principal órgano de
decisión era el poli puro es decir el
comité central del partido comunista
podría tener hasta 35 miembros que
discutían todas las decisiones hoy en
día sin embargo el politburó soviético
ya no existe y ahora tenemos esto
puede parecer es una caricatura pero
todo apunta a lo mismo una dictadura
cada vez más personalista un sistema
político donde un solo hombre tiene el
poder de tomar todas las decisiones sin
ningún contrapeso y si eso también se
nota en el ejército por ejemplo en casi
todos los países las fuerzas armadas
están dirigidas por el alto estado mayor
que a su vez depende del ministerio de
defensa sin embargo rusia cuenta con un
ejército especial una especie de guardia
pretoriana de putin hablamos de la
guardia nacional conocida por el nombre
de robar día
[Música]
este cuerpo fue creado por el propio
putin en el año 2016 tiene más de 340
mil efectivos y está dirigido
directamente por vladimir putin dicho de
otra forma que más de la tercera parte
de todos esos 850 mil soldados rusos
está fuera del ejército regular es decir
que no dependen ni del generalísimo ni
de sergei shoigú reciben órdenes
directas del presidente puede que os
sorprenda pero esto es una constante en
casi todos los regímenes autoritarios
muchos pensaríais que en principio el
ejército funciona mejor en una dictadura
militarista que no en una democracia sin
embargo los líderes autoritarios rara
vez confían plenamente en su ejército y
eso explica que putin haya creado su
propia guardia pretoriana
al principio esta guardia nacional no es
un cuerpo pensado para combatir en
guerra podríamos decir que son una
especie de policía militarizada al
estilo de la guardia civil en españa su
objetivo es el control territorial de la
propia rusia es decir luchar contra
grupos insurgentes grupos terroristas o
tomb hablamos de rusia reprimir las
protestas ahora bien recordáis que
oficialmente rusia no está en guerra
según el kremlin la invasión de ucrania
es una misión especial para des nacif y
carl un territorio lleno de insurgentes
anti rusos conclusión es muy probable
que putin está intentando enviar a su
guardia nacional y eso explica noticias
como esta 12 miembros del arroz guardias
fueron despedidos por su renuncia a
unirse a la invasión pensadlo bien esta
guardia nacional no está entrenada para
una guerra como tal así que enviarles al
frente es una sentencia de muerte para
muchos sin embargo recordad que hablamos
de todo un sistema político centrado en
la figura de vladímir putin quien se
atrevería a discutirlo en estos momentos
pensadlo así prácticamente todas las
figuras clave del ejército y de la
industria militar están puestas a dedo
por el presidente su partido rusia unida
ocupa casi los puestos del parlamento es
decir de 450 escaños que tienen la duma
rusa 325 están ocupados por el partido
de putin en otras palabras que no no
existen contrapesos al poder del kremlin
eso significa que nadie puede cuestionar
los errores de cálculo del propio putin
incluida la invasión de ucrania
a estas alturas nadie puede negar que
putin midió mal sus fuerzas porque
esperaba que sus tropas conquistarían
quib en unos pocos días y que los
ucranianos les recibirían con los brazos
abiertos en una democracia los servicios
de inteligencia habrían podido informar
al presidente con libertad incluso
llevarle la contraria y explicarle la
realidad en el campo los propios
generales podrían preparar una
estrategia mucho más realista basada en
un conocimiento exhaustivo de su músculo
militar pero recordad que en este caso
lo que estamos viendo es a un ex
directivo de la caja es decir alguien
sin formación militar tomando decisiones
sin que nadie le conteste y eso explica
fracasos como éste los oficiales
ucranianos dicen que las tropas rusas
abandonan las áreas cercanas aquí de
nuevo putin está fingiendo que la
invasión de ucraniano es una guerra y
espera que sea su guardia nacional y su
ejército quienes fijan que luchan en una
operación especial la pregunta ahora es
de verdad veremos cómo se reorganiza el
ejército ruso y vuelve a atacar kif
hasta qué punto rusia puede ganar esta
guerra sin tener que echar mano de sus
armas nucleares y otra pregunta de otro
tema completamente offtopic si las
hawaianas son la seña de identidad de
visual política los chalecos son la seña
de identidad de megaproyectos cuál será
el uniforme que nos pondremos en nuestro
nuevo canal visual economics y habéis
oído bien estamos a punto de lanzar un
canal hermano visual económico donde
como su propio nombre indica hablaremos
de todo lo que siempre habéis querido
saber sobre economía y nunca os habéis
atrevido a preguntar por ejemplo quién
es de verdad
george soros por qué es tan rico cuáles
son sus planes para europa pues bien de
eso tratará nuestro primer vídeo en
visual económico terminado en acá de
visual político y grace cuando
publicaremos ese vídeo pues ha apuntado
la fecha domingo 10 de abril a las 8 de
la tarde hora española no esperéis más
suscribiros ya al canal y apuntados la
fecha os esperamos en esta nueva
aventura os esperamos en visual
económico y por supuesto ya podéis
dejarnos en los comentarios como creéis
que iremos vestidos y después de este
anuncio después de estas noticias y este
vídeos ha gustado ya sabéis darle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]